The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: OK,
so it's five after.
We should probably start.
So last time we were
talking about honeycombs,
and I just wanted to
quickly kind of review
what we had talked
about, and then today I'm
going to start
deriving equations
for the mechanical properties
of the honeycombs, OK?
So this is a slide of
our honeycomb setup here.
These are the hexagonal
cells we're going to look at.
We talked about the
stress-strain behavior.
The curves on the left-hand
side are for compression
and the ones on the right-hand
side are for tension.
And so what we're
going to be doing today
is we're going to start out by
calculating a Young's modulus,
this slope here.
We're going to calculate the
stress plateaus for failure
by elastic buckling in
elastomeric honeycombs,
by failure from plastic yielding
in, say, a metal honeycomb,
and by failure by
a brittle crushing
in, say, a ceramic honeycomb.
And if we have time, we'll
get to the tension stuff.
I don't know if we'll get
to that today or next time.
So we're going to
start calculating
those properties today.
And these were the
deformation mechanisms.
Remember, we said the linear
elastic behavior was related
to bending of the cell
walls, and then the plateau
was related to buckling
if it was an elastomer.
And the plateau was
related to yielding
if it was, say, a metal
that had a yield point.
And then this was
sort of an overview
of the stress-strain
curve showing
those different regions, OK?
So what I'm going to
talk about today to start
is the linear elastic behavior.
And we're going to be starting
with the in-plane behavior.
So in-plane means in the
plane of the hexagonal cells.
And then next time we'll do the
out-of-plane behavior, this way
on.
So if I had to form
my little honeycomb
like this, what
initially happens
is the inclined cell walls bend.
So if you can see over
here, we've kind of
exaggerated it on this sketch.
So this wall here is bent.
This one here just kind of
moves along, goes for the ride.
And this guy here is bent.
So this is for
loading in the what
we're calling the x1
direction, sigma 1.
And the same kind
of thing happens
when we load in the
other direction,
in the sigma 2 direction,
these guys still bend.
Now the honeycomb
gets wider that way.
It gets shorter this
way, wider that way.
And we can calculate
the Young's modulus
if we can relate the load
on the beam in the moments
to this deflection here, right?
So the Young's modulus is going
to be related to the stiffness
and the stiffness is going to be
related to how much deformation
you get for a certain amount of
load that you put on the beam.
So I'm going to calculate the
modulus for the x1 direction,
the thing on the left there.
And you can do the same
thing for the x2 direction
on the right, but
I won't calculate
that because it's exactly
the same kind of process.
OK, so let me start here.
Get my chalk.
So I'm going to draw
a one-unit cell here.
So here's my unit
cell there, like that.
And this member
here is of length h.
That member there
is of length l.
That angle there is theta.
I'm going to say all the
walls have equal thickness,
and I'm going to call it t.
And I'm going to define an
x1 and x2 axis like this.
So the horizontal is x1 and
the vertical axis is x2.
And I'm going to say that I
apply a sort of global stress
to it, sigma 1.
So there's a stress in the one
direction there, sigma 1, OK?
And I'm going to say my
honeycomb has a depth
b into the page,
but the depth s--
is because the
honeycomb's prismatic,
the b's are always going to
cancel out of all the equations
that we're going to get,
because everything's
uniform in that direction.
And we can think about
a unit cell here,
and in the x1
direction, we could
say the length of our
unit cell is 2l cos theta.
So in the x1 direction,
that's our unit cell there,
and that's 2l cos of theta.
And in the x2
direction, you might
think that you go
from this vertex
up here down to
that vertex there,
but if you did that, then
on the next layer of cells,
you wouldn't have
the same distance.
So the unit length
in the x2 direction
is actually from here
to here, and then you
can see the next cell, you
would get the same thing.
You get this bit here
from the inclined member,
and then you would get h down
here from the next member.
So this bit here is equal to
h plus l times sine of theta.
So I can say in
the x2 direction,
the length of the unit cell
is h plus l sine theta, OK?
So that's kind of the setup.
And then what we want to look
at is that inclined member
that bends, we
want to look at how
this guy bends under the load.
And if we can relate the
forces on it to the deflection,
and we need the component
of the deflection in the one
direction, then we're going
to be able to get the modulus.
So I'm going to draw that
inclined member again
over here, and it's
going to see some loads
that I'm going to call
p, and that's going
to cause this thing to bend.
So I've kind of exaggerated it
there, but there's the bending.
And there's some end
deflection there, delta.
And there's moments at either
end of the beam, or either end
of that member, as well.
And this member
here has a length.
That length is l.
OK, are we good?
So it's just kind of the setup.
And I'm going to
draw the deflection
delta bigger over here.
So say that's delta.
That's the same parallel
as this guy here.
What I'm going to want is the
deflection in the x1 direction,
and when I come to calculate
the Poisson's ratio,
I'm going to want the
deflection in the x2 direction.
And if this angle here is
theta, between the horizontal
and the inclined member,
then this angle up here
is also theta, and so this
bit here is delta sine theta.
And this bit here
is delta cos theta.
Ba-doop-ba-doop-ba-doop.
So the Young's
modulus is going to be
the stress in the
one direction divided
by the strain in
the one direction.
So I need to get the
stress and the strain
in the one direction.
So here the stress
If I'm applying my load,
like this, sigma 1,
the stress in the
one direction is
going to be this load
p-- so this load,
say, p on this member here,
divided by this length
here, the unit cell
length, and then
divided by b into the board,
the width end of the board.
So sigma 1 is going to be p
divided by h plus l sine theta
times b.
And epsilon 1 is going to be
the strain in the one direction,
is going to be the deformation
in the one direction divided
by the unit cell length
in the one direction.
So that's going to be delta sine
theta divided by l cos theta.
So here, even though I've said
this unit cell is 2l cos theta,
there'd be two of
the members here
that would be twice that
deflection in the one
direction.
So it's, for one beam,
it's delta sine theta
over l cos theta.
Are we OK so far?
So far so good?
So for the hexagons,
because we're
going to figure out the
equations more or less exactly,
we're going to keep track of
all the geometrical factors.
When we come to the
foams, we're not
going to keep track of all
the geometrical factors.
So one of the things that makes
us look a little kind of hairy
is just the fact
that we're keeping
track of all these sines and
cosines and all the dimensions
and things.
All right, whoop.
So I need to be able to relate
my load p to my deformation
delta to get a stiffness out
of this, to get a modulus, OK?
So the way I do
that is, remember
in 3032, we did those
bending moment diagrams
and we did the
deflection of the beams?
This is where this
comes in handy.
So I'm going to draw my beam
a little bit differently now.
I'm going to turn
it on its side.
So this is still my
length l, but I'm
going to turn on my
side just so that you
can see it the same
kind of way we did
the bending moment diagrams.
So this is still my
length l across here.
And there's end
moments, M and M here.
And P sin theta is just
the perpendicular component
of the load p.
So p sin theta is just the
component perpendicular
to my beam.
So I could draw a
shear diagram here
and I could draw a bending
moment diagram here.
And, if you remember,
the shear diagram,
if I have no concentrated
load along here,
and I have no distributed load
along here, if this is zero,
down here, it's just going
to go up my P sin theta,
and then be horizontal, and then
come down by P sin theta, OK?
So that's the shear diagram.
And then the bending
moment diagram,
I'm going to draw down here.
So I've got some
moment at the end here,
and this would tend
to bend like that.
So this would be
a negative moment.
Remember, bending
moments were negative
if there was tension on the
top, and they were positive
if there was tension
on the bottom.
So over here we'd have
tension on the top,
so that would give us a
negative bending moment.
And then, if you also
remember, the moment
at a particular point is equal
to the integral from, say, A
to B-- well maybe I should
write this another way.
And B minus Ma is the
integral of the shear
diagram between the two points.
A little sloppy.
OK.
So if I know how I have
some moment here minus M,
if I integrate this
shear diagram up,
then this is just going
to be linear here,
and then I'm going to
be at plus M over there.
So if you look at this shear
and bending moment diagram,
it's really just the
same as the shear
and bending moment diagram
for two cantilevers that
are attached to each other.
So let me just draw over here
what the cantilever looks like.
Let's see.
So imagine I just had
a cantilever like this,
and I have some force
F on it like that.
And I call this
distance here capital L,
and I'm going to call that
deflection capital delta,
like that.
If I drew the shear
diagram for that,
there'd be a reaction here, F,
there would be a moment here,
FL.
Doot, doot, yup.
So this would look-- whoops--
it's a little too long.
Shear diagram here
would look like this.
That would be zero.
This would be FL.
And the moment diagram
would look like this.
Whoops.
A little too long again.
And that would be minus FL.
And that would be zero.
So do you see how the shear
and the bending moment diagram
here are really just
like two cantilevers, OK?
So I know that the deflection
for a cantilever, delta,
is equal to F capital
L cubed over 3EI.
It's kind of a standard
result. And so I
can take this and apply
that to this beam here.
So instead of working everything
out from first principles,
I'm just going to
say that my beam here
is like two cantilevers,
and instead of F, I've
got P sin theta.
And instead of capital
L here as the length,
I've got l/2 because l/2
would be the length of one
of the cantilevers.
OK, so for the
honeycomb, I've got
two cantilevers of length l/2.
So delta for the inclined
member on the honeycomb
is going to be 2--
because I've got
two cantilevers-- the
force, instead of having F,
I'm going to have P sin theta.
And instead of
having capital L, I'm
going to have l/2, all cubed.
So this is like F
capital L cubed over 3.
And here, the
modulus that I want
is the modulus of the
solid cell wall material,
so I'm going to call that ES,
and over the moment of inertia.
So you see how I've done it?
Is that OK?
So then I can just kind of
simplify this thing here.
I've got P sin theta l cubed.
1/2 cubed is going to be 1/8.
So this is going to be 2, if
that's 1/8, times 3 is 24.
So 2/24 is 12.
So I've got delta for
my honeycomb member
is P sin theta l
cubed over 12 EsI.
And here I is the moment
of inertia of that inclined
member of the honeycomb.
And that's BT cubed over 12, OK?
So B is the depth into the
board, and T is the thickness.
We'll cube that
and divide by 12.
It's a rectangular section.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What was ES again?
LORNA GIBSON: ES is the
Young's modulus of the solid
that it's made from.
So clearly, if my
honeycomb is made up
of these members,
whatever material
the members are made of is
going to affect the stiffness
of the whole thing.
Are we good?
Because once we have
this part, then we just
combine these equations
for the stress
and the strain in
the one direction.
And we have this equation
relating delta and P,
and we're going to be able to
get our Young's modulus, OK?
We're happy?
OK.
All right.
So I'm going to call the Young's
modulus in the one direction E
star 1.
So everything with a star refers
to a cellular solid property,
and 1 because it's
in one direction.
So that's going to be
sigma 1 over epsilon 1.
So if I go back up
there, I can say
sigma 1 is equal to P divided
by h plus l sin theta b.
And epsilon 1 is equal to delta
sine theta in the denominator
over l cos theta.
And now instead of
having delta here,
I can substitute this
thing here in for delta.
And then I'm going to able
to cancel the P's out.
So delta was equal to P sine
theta l cubed over 12 Es,
and there was an I,
a moment of inertia,
and I was equal to
bt cubed over 12.
And let's see here.
So that's delta.
And there's another
sine theta here
so I'm just going to square
that sine theta there.
So now the P's cancel out.
The b's are going to cancel out.
The 12s are going to cancel out.
And I'm going to rearrange
this a little bit.
So I'm going to
write Young's modulus
of the solid out in the front.
Then I've got a
term here of t cubed
and I'm going to multiply
that by 1/l squared,
and then everything
else-- well, let's see.
We can take this l cubed here.
I can take that.
Put it underneath
that, so that's
going to give me t/l cubed.
And then I've got an h
plus l sine theta here,
and I've got an l
there, so I'm going
to take that to be
h/l plus sine theta.
Boop-boop-da-doop.
So I've got this term with
[? h/l's ?] in the thetas.
There's a cos theta
from the numerator here.
This term here turns
into h/l plus sine theta,
and then I've got my sine
squared thetas down there.
And that's my result
for the Young's modulus
in the one direction.
OK?
Let's make sure
that seems right.
It seems good.
OK.
So one of the things
to notice here
is there's three types of
parameters that are important.
So one is the solid properties.
So the Young's modulus of
the solid comes into this.
So the stiffness
of the whole thing
depends on the stiffness
of whatever it's made from.
There's this factor
of t/l cubed--
that's directly related to the
relative density or the volume
fraction of solids.
So what this is saying is the
relative density goes as t/l,
so the Young's modulus
depends on the cube
of the relative density.
So it's very sensitive
to the relative density.
And then this factor
here really is just
a factor that depends
on the cell geometry.
Remember when we talked about
the structure of the honeycomb,
we said we could define the cell
geometry by the ratio of h/l
and theta, OK?
And since we often deal with
regular hexagonal honeycombs,
I'm just going to
write down what
this works out to be for
regular hexagonal honeycombs.
So for a regular hexagonal
honeycomb, h/l is 1.
All the members have
the same length.
And theta's 3, and
the modulus works out
to 4 over root 3 times
Es times t/l cubed, OK?
So do you see how
we do these things?
So all the other properties
work in a similar kind of way.
You have to say something about
what the sort of bulk stress
is on the whole
thing and relate that
to the loads on the members.
You have to say something
about how the loads are related
to deflections, or when
we look at the strengths,
we're going to look
at moments and how
the moments are
related to failure
moments of one sort or another.
But it's all just like a
little structural analysis, OK?
Are we good?
You good, Teddy?
I thought you were going
to put your hand up?
No?
You're OK?
OK.
OK, so the next property
we're going to look at
is Poisson's ratio.
And I'm going to look at it for
loading in the one direction.
So Poisson's 1 2, say
we load uniaxially
in the one direction,
we want to know
what the strain is
in the two direction,
it's minus epsilon
2 over epsilon 1.
And again, if I look
at my inclined member,
and I say that member's going
to bend something like that,
and that's my deflection
delta there, and, say,
got the same x1 and x2 axes.
And again, if I
look at delta here,
it's the same little
sketch I had before.
That's delta sine theta.
And this is delta cos theta.
I'm going to need
those components to get
the two strains in the
different directions.
So epsilon 1 is going to be
delta sine theta over l cos
theta.
And if I'm compressing it,
that would get shorter.
And we get-- and
epsilon 2 is going
to be delta cos theta divided
by h plus l sine theta.
And that would get longer.
So these two have
opposite signs,
and so the minus sign is
going to disappear here.
Doodle-doodle-doot.
So then I can get
my Poisson's ratio
by just taking the
ratio of those two guys.
So I could put a
minus sign there
and say that's the
opposite sign to epsilon 2.
Then this would be delta cos
theta divided by h plus l sine
theta.
And epsilon 1 would be delta
sine theta over l cos theta.
And the thing that's
convenient here
is that the two deltas
just cancel out.
So the Poisson's ratio is
the ratio of two strains.
Each one of the strains is going
to be proportional to delta,
and so the two deltas are
just going to cancel out.
And so I can rewrite
this thing here
as cos squared theta
divided by h/l plus sine
theta times sine theta.
And so one of the
interesting things
to notice that the
Poisson's ratio only
depends on the cell geometry.
It doesn't depend on what solid
the material is made from.
It doesn't depend on
the relative density.
It only depends on
the cell geometry.
Oops.
OK, and then we
can also work out
what the value is for a
regular hexagonal cell.
And if we plug-in h is equal
to l and theta's equal to 30,
you get that it's equal to 1.
So one is kind of an unusual
number for a Poisson's ratio.
When we think of most
materials, it's around 0.3,
so it's kind of unusual
that it's that large.
The other thing
that's interesting
is that it can be negative.
So if theta is less than 0, then
you can get a negative value.
If the cos squared is going
to be a positive value,
but you've got a sine theta
down here, then that's going
to give you a negative value.
So you can get negative values.
So let me just
plug in an example.
So say h/l is equal
to 2, and theta
is equal to minus 30 degrees,
then this turns out to be 3/4.
So cos of 30 is root 3/2,
so square of that is 3/4.
h/l is 2, sine theta is
1/2, but it's minus 1/2.
So 2 minus 1/2 is 1 and 1/2.
And then the sine
theta is minus 1/2.
And so it works
out to be minus 1
for that particular combination.
And I brought my
little honeycomb
that has a negative
Poisson's ratio in.
So this guy here--
let's see, I don't
think there's an overhead here.
No overhead?
Guess not.
I'll just pass it around.
So if you take it, put
your hands on the flat side
and load it like this, and
don't smoosh it like that.
Just load it a little bit,
because you [? want to be ?]
linear elastic.
If you load it
just a little bit,
you can see that as
you push it this way,
it contracts in
sideways that way.
So don't smash it.
Just load it a little bit
and you can kind of see it
with your hands.
And if you put on a
piece of lined paper,
it's easier to see it.
OK, so that's kind
of interesting.
So are we good with getting
the Young's modulus in the one
direction and the
Poisson's ratio
for loading in one direction?
OK, so you can do the
same sort of thing
to get the Young's
modulus in the two
direction and the
Poisson's ratio
for loading in
the two direction.
And you get slightly
different formulas,
but it's the same idea.
And you can also get a
shear modulus this way,
and in-plane shear modulus.
It's a little bit-- the geometry
of it's a little bit more
complicated.
So all of those things
are derived in the book,
in the cellular solids book.
So if you wanted to figure
those out, look at that,
you could look at the book.
So let me just comment on that.
All right, so those are the
in-plane linear elastic moduli,
and remember we said
that four of them
describe the in-plane properties
for an anisotropic honeycomb.
And you can use that
reciprocal relationship
to relate the two Young's moduli
and the two Poisson's ratios.
All right, so the next
thing I wanted to talk about
was the compressive strength.
So let me just back
up here a second.
So if we go back
to here, remember
we had for an
elastomeric honeycomb,
this stress plateau was
related to elastic buckling.
So we're going to look at
that buckling stress first.
And this plateau here
is related to yielding.
And then we'll look at
the yielding stress next.
And then this plateau
here is related
to a brittle sort of crushing,
and we'll do that one third.
So we're going to go
through each of those next.
And this is kind of a schematic
for the elastic buckling.
So when you look at
the elastic buckling,
one of the things
to note is that when
you load the
honeycomb this way on,
if you load it in
the one direction,
you don't get buckling.
It just sort of
continues to-- whoops,
if I can keep it in plane.
It all just kind of
folds up, so you just
get larger and larger
bending deflections.
You don't really get buckling.
But when you load it this way
on, these vertical members
here, the ones of length
h, they're going to buckle.
So, see if I do that,
my honeycomb looks
like those cells up on
the schematic there, OK?
So, whoops.
So we're going to look at the
compressive stress or strength
next.
That's sometimes called
the plateau stress.
So we can get cell collapse
by elastic buckling,
if, for instance, the
honeycomb is made of a polymer.
And then the stress-strain
curve looks something like that.
And what happens
is you get buckling
of those vertical struts
throughout the honeycomb
And then you could also
get a stress plateau
by plastic yielding.
And what happens when
you get plastic yielding
is you get localization
of the deformation.
So one band of cells will begin
to yield initially, and then
as the deformation proceeds,
that deformation ban will
propagate and get
bigger and bigger,
and you get a wider
and wider band
of cells yielding and failing.
So you get
localization of yield,
and then as
deformation progresses,
the deformation band widens
throughout the material.
So if I go back and look--
if I look at this one
here, when you look at
this middle picture here,
you can see how one band of
cells has started to collapse
and started to fail.
And as you continue to compress
that in the one direction,
this way on, then more
and more neighboring cells
are going to collapse
and the whole thing
will get wider until the
whole thing has collapsed.
And that's kind
of characteristic
of the plastic failure.
And then the third possibility
is brittle crushing.
And then you get these
kind of serrated plateau.
And the peaks and valleys
correspond to fractures
of individual cell walls.
OK, so we're going
to start off with
the elastic buckling failure.
And I'm going to call these
plateau stresses sigma star,
for the sort of
compressive strength.
And el means it's
by elastic buckling.
And as I mentioned, you don't
get it in the one direction.
The cells just fold up.
You only get it for loading
in the two direction,
so it's going to
be sigma star el 2.
Oops, need a different
piece of chalk.
So you get this elastic
buckling for loading
in the x2 direction, and the
cell walls of length h buckle.
And you don't get it for
loading in the one direction,
the cells just fold up.
So again, let me draw a
little kind of unit cell here.
And here is our stress
sigma 2, like that.
And here's our little
wall of length h
that's going to buckle.
So if I load it up, initially
it'll be linear elastic.
And then eventually,
at some stress,
it will get large enough that
this wall here will buckle.
And we can relate
to that plateau
stress, or that
compressive stress,
to some Euler buckling load.
So you remember, if we have
a pin-ended column, so just
a single column,
pins on either end,
the Euler buckling
load says you get
buckling when the critical load
is equal to some end constraint
factor, n squared.
So n squared pi squared E,
and here it's E of the solid,
I over the length of the
column, and in this case,
the column length
is h-- so h squared.
OK, so that's just
the Euler formula.
And here, n is an end
constraint factor.
And if you remember
for a pin column,
so if our column is pinned
at both ends like that,
and just buckles out like
that, then n is equal to 1.
And if the column is
fixed at both ends,
something like that, then
the column looks like that
and then it's equal to 2, OK?
So if I know what the end
condition is, I know what n is
and I can use my
Euler formula here.
So the trick to this is that
it's not so obvious what n is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, when you're
loading in the x2 direction
here, the first thing
you're going to get
is the incline
members deforming?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
at some point,
you hit a P critical
that will cause
the vertical members to buckle?
LORNA GIBSON: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's exactly right.
Hello.
So the trick here is
that we don't really
know what this n is, initially.
They're not really
pinned, pinned;
they're not fixed, fixed.
And if you think about the
setup with the honeycomb here,
the constraint on
that vertical member
depends on how stiff the
adjacent members are.
So you can kind
of imagine, if I'm
looking at one of
these vertical members
here, if these two adjacent
inclined members were
big honking thick things, it
would be more constrained.
And if they were little thin,
kind of teeny little membranes,
it would be less constrained.
And you can think of it in
terms of a rotational stiffness,
that when the honeycomb
buckles, you kind of
see the member h goes from
being horizontal to sort
of it buckles over like this.
But that whole end
joint, see the end joint
at the top here or the end
joint at the bottom, that
whole joint rotates
a little bit.
And so there's some rotational
stiffness of that joint.
And that rotational stiffness
depends on how stiff
the member h is and how stiff
those inclined members are.
So there's a thing called the
elastic line analysis that you
can use to calculate what n is.
And basically what
that does is it matches
the rotational stiffness
of the column h
with the rotational stiffness
of those inclined members.
So we're not going
to get into that.
I'm just going to tell
you what the answer is.
But if you want
to go through it,
it's in an appendix in the book.
So you can look at
it, if you want.
So here I'm just going to
say that the constraint
n depends on the stiffness of
the adjacent inclined members.
And we can find that
by something called
the elastic line analysis.
And if you have the book,
you can look in the appendix
and see how that works.
But essentially
what it does is it
matches the rotational
stiffness of the column h
with the rotational stiffness
of the inclined members.
So what you find is that n
depends on the ratio of h/l.
And I'm just going to give
you a table with a few values.
So for h/l equal to 1,
then n is equal to 0.686.
For h equal to 1.5,
it's equal to 0.76.
And for h/l equal to
2, it's equal to 0.806.
OK, so now if we
have values for n,
we can just substitute in to
get the critical buckling load.
And if I take that
load and divide it
by the area of
the unit cell, I'm
going to get my buckling stress.
So it's pretty
straightforward from this.
So my buckling stress is
going to be that critical load
divided by my unit cell area.
So it's divided by the unit
cell length in the x1 direction
to l cos theta times the
depth b into the page.
So it's equal to n squared
pi squared Es times I.
And I is bt cubed over 12.
Divided by the length of
the column, h squared,
and then divided by the area of
the unit cell, 2l cos theta b,
OK?
And I can rearrange
that somewhat
to put it in terms of
dimensionless groups.
So if I pull all
the constants out,
it's n squared pi squared
over 24 times the modulus
of the solid, t/l cubed
in the numerator divided
by h/l squared times cos
theta in the denominator.
So again, you can see
that the buckling stress,
the compressive sort of
elastic collapse stress,
depends on the solid property.
So here is the modulus
of the cell wall in here.
Depends on the relative
density through t/l cubed.
And then it depends on the cell
geometry through h/l cos theta,
and n depends on
h/l as well, OK?
And then we can
do the same thing
where we figure out what it is
for regular hexagonal cells.
And it's 0.22 Es
times t/l cubed.
And then we can also notice
that since E in the 2 direction,
for a regular hexagonal
cell, E is the same in the 2
direction and the 1 direction.
It's isotropic.
So E2 is also equal to 4 over
root 3 Es times t/l cubed.
That's equal to-- whoops-- it's
equals to 2.31 Es t/l cubed.
And we can say that the strain
at which that buckling happens
is just equal to a constant.
And for regular
hexagonal honeycombs,
it works out to a strain of 10%.
Are we good?
So we have a buckling load.
We divide by the area.
The only complicated
thing is finding n.
And you can find it by this
elastic line analysis thing.
So each of these
calculations is like
a little structural
analysis, only
on a little teeny weeny
scale of the cells.
So you see where my background
in civil engineering
comes in handy.
Yup.
OK.
So the honeycombs
involve the most sort
of complicated equations.
When we come to do
the foams, we're
going to use a
dimensional analysis
and all the equations are
going to be much simpler.
So this is the most
kind of tedious part
of the whole thing.
So the next property
I want to look at
is the plastic collapse stress.
Say we had a metal
honeycomb and we
wanted to calculate the stress
plateau for a metal honeycomb.
So we have this
little schematic here,
and say we load it in
the one direction again.
So we're loading it here.
And we've got some
load P, like that.
And if we have our honeycomb, we
load it this way on, initially,
the cell walls bend.
And you have linear
elasticity and you
have some Young's modulus.
But if you have a metal, if
you continue to deform it
and you continue to
load it more and more,
eventually you're going to hit
the yield stress and the cell
wall.
So the stresses in
the cell wall are
going to hit the yield stress.
And initially, the
stresses are just
going to be-- remember,
if you have a beam,
the stresses are maximum at the
top and the bottom of the beam.
So initially you're
going to hit the yield
stress at the top and the
bottom of the beam first.
But as you continue
to load it, you're
going to end up yielding
the cross-section
through the entire section.
So the entire section
is going to be yielded.
And once the entire
section yields,
it forms what's called
a plastic hinge.
Once the whole thing's yielded,
then you can add more force
and the thing just rotates.
And because it rotates,
it's called a plastic hinge.
You know, if you
take a coat hanger,
and you bend it back and forth
and bend it back and forth.
If you bend it enough, you form
a plastic hinge because it just
can bend easily.
So these little schematics
here, if you look at the,
say, one of these
inclined members,
the moments are
maximum at the end.
So Remember when we had the
linear elastic deformation
and I looked at the little
bending moment diagram?
The moments are
maximum at the ends,
and you're going to form
those plastic hinges initially
at the ends.
And so these little ellipsey
things here, all the ends,
those kind of show where
the plastic hinges are.
So those plastic
hinges are forming.
So here's for loading
in the x1 direction,
and here's for loading in
the x2 direction, there.
So the thing we
want to calculate
is what stress does it take
to form those plastic hinges
and get this kind of
plastic plateau stress?
OK, so we can say we get failure
by yielding in the cell walls.
And I'm going to say the yield
strength of the cell wall
is sigma ys.
So sigma y for yield
and s for the solid.
And the plastic hinge forms
when the cross-section has fully
yielded.
So let's look at the
stress distribution
through the cross-section
when its first linear elastic.
So say that's the
thickness t of the member.
And if the beam
was linear elastic,
the stress would just [? vary ?]
linearly, like that, right?
And this would be the
neutral axis, here,
where there is no normal stress.
So that's what happens
if it's linear elastic,
and I'm hoping you remember
something vaguely like that.
Sounds good?
But as we increase
the load on it,
and we increase the
sort of external stress,
this stress in the member is
going to get bigger and bigger,
and eventually, that's going
to reach the yield stress, OK?
And once that reaches
the yield stress,
if we continue to
load it, what happens
is the yielding propagates
down through the thickness
of the thing here.
So we get yielding through
the whole cross-section.
So let me scoot over here.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
LORNA GIBSON: Yup?
AUDIENCE: When it starts to
yield, does this curve change?
LORNA GIBSON: Yes.
I'm going to draw it for you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
LORNA GIBSON: That's
the next step.
That would be the next thing.
OK, so once the stress
at the outer fiber
is the yield strength
of the solid,
then the yielding begins and it
progresses through the section
as the load increases.
So the stress distribution
starts to look something
like this once it yields.
OK, so that's sigma
y of the solid.
Actually, let me rub
that out because then I
can show you something else.
So in 3D, this would be through
the thickness of the beam.
That would be the thickness
of the beam there.
And boop, boop.
It would look
something like that.
OK?
And then this is still
our neutral axis here.
And then eventually, as
you load it more and more,
the whole cross-section
is going to yield.
Whoops.
And I'm assuming that the
material is elastic, perfectly
plastic.
So the stress-strain
curve from the solid I'm
idealizing as-- whoops.
That's not quite right.
I'm idealizing as that, OK?
So when you get to
this point here,
the entire cross-section
has yielded,
and that means you
form the plastic hinge.
The idea here is
that the section then
just rotates like a pin.
All right.
So we can figure out
the plateau stress
that corresponds
to this by looking
at the moment that's associated
with the plastic hinge
formation.
So there's some internal
moment associated with that.
And then equating that
to the applied moment
from the applied stress.
So doodle-loodle-oot.
Let me see me,
maybe back up here.
So there's some-- if I have
the stress distribution
here, I could say this
whole kind of stress block
is equivalent to
some force acting out
like that and some force
acting out like that.
It would be sigma ys times
b comes t/2 would be f.
And I can say there's
some plastic moment.
If I think of the force
here and the force there,
they act as a couple and
they have some moment,
and that's called
the plastic moment.
So that's like an
internal moment
when the plastic hinge forms.
So I'll say the internal
moment at the formation
of a plastic hinge.
I'm going to call that
Mp, for plastic moment.
And we can work out Mp
by looking at that stress
distribution when the entire
cross section has yielded.
The force F is going to be
sigma ys times b comes t/2.
It's the stress times that area.
And then the moment arm between
the two forces is also t/2.
And so that plastic
moment is just sigma ys
bt squared over 4, OK?
Are we good?
Sonya?
AUDIENCE: What's the
second [INAUDIBLE]?
LORNA GIBSON: OK, so
this is the force.
This thing here is
the force F. And I
have to-- if I'm
getting a moment,
I'm saying that that force,
if I doot-doot-doot--
the distance between those
two forces there is t/2.
So each force acts through
the middle of the block,
and so the distance
between [? it is ?] t/2.
And I'm going to equate that
moment to the applied moment
from the sort of applied stress.
And then if I go back to my
inclined member-- whoops,
let's see.
Let me get a little
more inclined.
That's my inclined member,
there, of length l.
I've got modes p
that are applied
at the end from sigma 1.
And I've got moments that
are induced at the ends.
And that angle there
would be theta.
This length here
is l, like that.
And if I just use
static equilibrium
on that, I can say
that I've got 2 times
the moment, so I've got
one at each end-- they're
both the same sign--
minus P. And then
the distance between these
two P's, say I take moments
about here, I've got M
applied plus M applied,
I've got minus P
times l sine theta.
That's equal to 0.
So the applied moment there
is just Pl sine theta over 2.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to equate
this applied moment
with this plastic
moment, and I'm
going to relate P to my
applied stress sigma 1.
And then I'm going to get a
strength in terms of the yield
strength of the solid, there's
going to be a t/l factor
and there's going to be
some geometrical factor.
So that's just the last step.
Boop-ba-doop-ba-doop.
So we get plastic
collapse of the honeycomb.
And the stress I'm going to call
sigma star plastic with a 1,
because I'm going to look
at the one direction.
And that happens when that
internal plastic moment
equals the applied moment.
So let's see.
I've got that.
Let me also write
down over here,
I've also got this sigma
1 is equal to P over
h plus l sine theta times b.
So here I can write P in terms
of sigma 1, in this thing.
And then write that,
get the applied moment
in terms of that, and
then equate it to that.
So this term on
the left-hand side
corresponds to this expression
for the applied moment
where I've plugged in.
For P, I've plugged in
sigma 1 times h plus l sine
theta times b.
And that's my plastic moment
on the right-hand side.
So if I just rearrange
this, I can then
solve for this plastic
collapse stress.
So it's equal to the yield
strength of the solid times
t/l squared, and then times
another geometrical factor.
2 times h/l plus sine
theta times sine theta.
Doop-doop-doop.
So the same kind
of thing, there's
a solid property, a t/l,
a relative density term,
in then a cell geometry term.
And we can calculate with this
for regular hexagonal cells.
And we can do a similar
kind of calculation
for loading in the
other direction.
And you can get a shear strength
if you want to do that, too.
AUDIENCE: If you're going
in the other direction,
only the E or the M
apply changes, right?
[? Or ?] like that section.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, this
thing here is the same.
AUDIENCE: That stays.
LORNA GIBSON: Right.
And this is-- there's a
different geometry to it.
Because now you're
loading it this way on.
OK, so we've calculated an
elastic buckling plateau
stress and a sort of plastic
collapse plateau stress.
And if you have thin enough
walled, say, even aluminum
honeycombs, then
the elastic buckling
could precede the
plastic collapse.
And so I'm just going to work
out what the criterion would
be for that to happen.
So the two stresses
can be equated.
And then that's going to
give us some criterion.
So the two are equal, I'm
just going to write down
the equations that we had.
So the buckling
stress was n squared
pi squared over 24 times
E of the solid times t/l
cubed divided by h/l
squared times cos of theta.
And the plastic collapse
stress for the 2 direction
was sigma ys times t/l squared
divided by 2 cos squared theta.
So I can write this-- because
this has a t/l cubed term,
and that has a t/l
squared term, I
can write this in terms
of a t/l critical.
So if I leave it t/l here
and I put everything else
on the other side, I've got
12 over n squared pi squared,
then h/l squared over cos
theta times sigma ys over Es.
So if t/l is less
than that, I'm going
to get elastic buckling first.
And if it's more
than that, I'm going
to get plastic yielding first.
And we can work
out an exact number
for regular
hexagonal honeycombs,
so I'm going to do that.
So if I have a
particular geometry,
I can figure out what n is.
So for regular
hexagonal honeycombs,
t/l critical just
works out to 3 times
the yield strength of the
solid over the Young's modulus
of the solid.
So if we know that
ratio of the yield
strength of the
modulus of the solid,
we can get some idea of what
that critical t/l would be.
So we'll do that next.
AUDIENCE: And you said if t/l
is less than that critical,
then you're going to
get the yielding first.
LORNA GIBSON: No, if it's less,
you get the buckling first.
If it's really skinny,
it tends to buckle first.
So, for example, for metals, the
yield strength over the modulus
is roughly 0.002, like
the 0.2% yield strength.
And so that means
that t/l, the sort
of transition or the
critical value is at 0.6%.
So most metal honeycombs
are denser than that.
That's a pretty low density.
But if we look at polymers,
you can get polymers
with a yield strength
relative to the modulus
of about 3% to 5%, and
then that critical t/l is
equal to about 10%, 15%.
So low-density polymers
with yield points
may buckle before they yield.
So we have one more of these
compressive plateau stresses,
and that's for the
brittle honeycomb.
So I don't think I'm going
to finish this today,
but let me set it up and then
we'll finish it next time.
So the idea here is that if
you have a ceramic honeycomb--
remember I showed you some
of those ceramic honeycombs--
that if you compress them, they
can fail by a brittle crushing
mode.
So ceramic honeycombs can
fail in a brittle manner.
And again, initially there
would be some cell wall bending,
but at some point, you're going
to reach the bending strength
of the material.
And bending strengths are
called modulus of rupture.
So you reach the modulus of
rupture of the cell wall.
So I'm not going to
write the equations down
today because we're not
going to get very far,
so I'll do that next time.
But we're going to set
this up exactly the same
as we did for the last one,
for the plastic yielding.
But instead of getting
that sort of blocky,
fully yielded cross-section
stress distribution,
we're just going to have
the linear elastic stress
distribution, and when
the maximum stress
reaches that modulus
[? rupture, ?] the thing's
going to fail.
So the form of the
equations is going
to be very similar to what we
had for the plastic collapse
stress, but there's a slightly
different geometrical factor--
that's all.
So we'll do that next time.
And then next time
we're also going
to talk about the
tensile behavior
of honeycombs in-plane.
We'll work out a
fracture toughness
and then we'll start talking
about the out-of-plane
properties, as well.
So on Wednesday, we'll do the
out-of-plane properties, OK?
So hopefully we'll finish
the out-of-plane properties
Wednesday.
And then next week,
I was going to talk
about some natural
materials that
have honeycomb-like structures,
so things like wood and cork,
OK?
All right, so this is the
kind of most equationy lecture
in the whole course.